[Music]
good evening welcome to tucker carlson
tonight got to be honest not many of us
in the press are looking forward to the
2020 Democratic primary just hours ago
it felt like it was going to be an
exhausting miserable affair the current
field is a mixture of fossils extremists
and power-hungry cynics willing to say
anything and hurt anybody to get a hold
on the White House but things have
changed a new candidate has entered the
race a man untethered from the old ways
possibly even from the conventional
restrictions of physics time and space
more a spiritual force than a temporal
leader more a poet than a politician
ladies and gentlemen the author of our
Redemption beta or orc better or war the
social media phenom despite his loss to
Ted Cruz the rock and roll loving 46
year old caught the nation's attention
[Music]
his offbeat social-media posts appealing
to a younger generation even taking a
skateboarding at Whataburger his Senate
candidacy winning the endorsement of
celebrities like Beyonce bado loves rock
and roll says GMA he's not like everyone
else he doesn't do stuffy speeches or
policy programs he's not gonna bore you
with entitlement projections or some
scary stuff about the Korean Peninsula
Beto's got a skateboard and where's
Nirvana t-shirts his vision for this
country is 1995 that was a year he was
living way uptown and this walk-up and
working as a Manning and knew this dude
on West 112 Street with some of the
stickiest but in Manhattan indica a
little heavy but sweet it was a good
time
bata wants to bring us back to that time
when the press is totally on board I saw
him for the first time just a month ago
when he sat down with Oprah and me and
the rest of the people in the audience
thought wow this guy has this dynamic
positive energy yeah he has that raw
talent he is very kind of Obama s and
indeed the women voted for him in the
suburbs of Houston who hadn't voted
Democrat before because they had a kind
of better crush going on you know he's
wholesome and he's earnest he's got that
magic dust of course his son his name
Ulysses I love that that's his son he
has that gleam in his eye somebody evan
smith and the texas tribune said seeing
him is like it's like a jesus christ
superstar seeing this guy in front of
people he's got that celebrity aura
about him and in that moment he was
owning that you heard it Beto's got that
magic dust oye does at least an eight
ball though the guy in 112 Street has
more if you need it Beto's got great
hair to beat that combo actual voting
doesn't begin for months but beta was
already America's spiritual president
and by the way that's a much cleaner way
to run for office real elections the
ones with voters sometimes end like this
so we have quite a bit of big news to
report we can call now that the Texas
race will go to Ted Cruz the incumbent
Republican that Ted Cruz win over better
or orc significant
well that election was a bummer so beta
split soon after on a solo road trip it
was a hole me and you and a dog named
boo kind of thing the sort of trip that
Kerouac or Steinbeck would had taken
just the hum of the engine and the black
ribbon of the open road time to feed the
soul also a time to stage a series of
publicity shots for snapchat and
Instagram while simultaneously blogging
the whole thing
timeless stuff an all-american
redemption story bado came back a better
man he understood the running for
president thing was not for him is there
a scenario where you run for president
in 2020 no you will never run for
president no boudoir no period no Punto
baby down on the border where the people
are authentic and speak various
languages at once that means yes I am
running for president just as soon as I
can hire a staff of consultants and line
up some billionaires to fund it but for
now I will lie about my plans and that's
exactly what Vito did and so here we are
in the age of bado what's the plan man
what are we doing what's next well
what's next bado says is understanding
that the things that we think of as
terrifying threats to the country are
actually perfectly cool like more than
20 million people using fake identities
to live illegally inside the United
States that's not a problem that's the
best man all of us wherever you live can
acknowledge that if immigration is a
problem it's the best possible problem
for this country to have yeah it's the
best problem hard to think of a better
problem illegal immigration is such a
cool problem to have we ought to have
more let's knock down the border walls
dude if you could would you kick the
wall down now here yes like you have a
wall absolutely knock it down I'll take
the wall do you think the city you think
if there's a referendum here in this
city that would I do yeah it's fine but
that's not to say bado doesn't seem
problems on the horizon he does and when
he does his dough brown-eyes cloud a
little and he stares off into the
distance to consider a wholistic so
just like James Dean would have done if
he had lived to be Beto's age and could
skateboard
Beto's says global warming is a major
bummer global warming could make us go
extinct like the dinosaurs the museum's
man dead forever
some will criticize the green new deal
for being too bold or being unmanageable
but I tell you what I haven't seen
anything better that addresses this
singular crisis that we face a crisis
that could at its worst lead to
extinction extinction
that's what Beto's fighting against what
else is he for what's a fair question
but honestly it's not really clear we
checked his campaign website there's a
picture that it says bado for America
and English the one in Spanish says
baito for all we couldn't find any
actual policies even about fighting
extinction we did find a sweet bado tote
bag just 30 bucks and you don't even
have to pledge to NPR to get it though
you probably already have you only get
one it's awesome